you've written about binary planets what
what's and that they're surprisingly
common
or they might be surprisingly common
what's the difference between a large
Moon and binary plants what what are
binding planets what uh what's
interesting to say here about giant
rocks flying through space and orbiting
each other the thing that's interesting
about binary objects is that they're
very common in the universe binary stars
are everywhere but the majority of stars
seem to live in binary systems when we
look at the outer edges of the solar
system we see binary Kuiper Belt objects
all the time asteroids basically bound
to one another Pluto shown is kind of an
example of that it's a 10 Mass ratio
system it almost is by many definitions
a binary Planet but now it's a dwarf
planet so yeah I don't know we can call
that now but we know we know that these
you know the universe likes to make
things in pairs yeah um so you're saying
our sun is an in cell it's looking so
most things are dating they're in
relationships and ours is alone
it's not a complete freak of the
universe to be alone but it is
um it's more common for sunlight Stars
if you count up all this on next stars
in the universe about half of the sun
like Star systems are in binary or
trinary systems and the other half are
single but because those binaries are
two or three stars then cumulatively
maybe like a third of all some like
stars are single I'm trying hard to not
anthropomorphize the relationship that
starts up with each other but yeah
yeah that's yeah I've met those folks
also
um so is there something interesting to
learn about the habitability the how
that affects the probability of
habitable worlds when they kind of
couple up like that in those different
ways well it depends we're talking about
the stars of the planet certainly if
Stars couple up that has a big influence
on the how to Ability
um of course this is very famous from
Star Wars Tatooine in Star Wars there's
a binary star system and you have Luke
Skywalker looking at the sunset and
seeing two stars come down and for you
years we thought that was purely a
product of George Lucas's incredibly
creative mind and we didn't think that
planets would exist around binary star
systems it seems like two tumultuous an
environment for a quiescent planetary
disc circumstellar disk to form plants
from and yet uh one of the astounding
discoveries from Kepler was that these
appear to be quite common in fact as far
as we can tell they're just as common
around binary stars as single Stars the
only uh caveat to that is that you don't
get plants close into binary Stars they
have like a clearance region in on the
inside where plants maybe they form
there but they don't last
they are dynamically unstable in that
zone but once you get out to about the
distance that the Earth orbits the Sun
or even a little bit closer in you start
to find plants emerging and so that's
the right distance for liquid water
sorry distance for potentially life on
those parts and so there may vary will
be plenty of Habitual plants around the
binary Stars binary plants is a little
bit different binary plants I don't
think we have
um any serious connection of plant
venerity to habitability certainly when
we investigated it that wasn't our drive
that this is somehow the solution to
life in the universe or anything
it was really just a like all good
science questions a curiosity driven
question what's the dynamic are they
legit orbiting each other as they orbit
this uh the star so the formation
mechanism proposed here
um because it is very difficult to form
two Proto plants close to each other
like this they were generally merged
within the disc and so that's why you
normally get single planets but you
could have something like Jupiter and
Saturn form at separate distances they
could dynamically be scattered in
towards one another and basically not
quite Collide but have a very close on
encounter now because uh tidal forces
increase dramatically as the distance
decreases between two objects the tides
can actually dissipate the kinetic
energy and bring them bound into one
another so that seemed when we you know
when you first hear that you think that
seems fairly contrived that you'd have
the conditions just right to get these
ties to cause a capture but numerical
simulations have shown that about 10 of
planet planet encounters
are shown to produce something like
binary planets which is a startling
prediction
um and so that seems at odds with
naively the exoplank catalog for which
we know of so far are no binary plants
and we propose one of the resolutions to
this might be that the binary planets
are just incredibly difficult to detect
which is also counter-intuitive because
remember how they form us through this
tidal mechanism and so they form
extremely close to each other so the
distance that IO is away from Jupiter
just a few planetary radii they're
almost touching one another and they're
just tightly locked facing each other
for eternity and so in that
configuration as it transits across the
start it kind of looks like you can't
really resolve those two planets it just
looks like one planet to you that's
going across the star the temporal
resolution of the data is rarely good
enough to distinguish that and so you'd
see one Transit but in fact it's two
planets very close together which are
transiting at once and so yeah we wrote
a paper just recently where we developed
some techniques to try and get around
this problem and hopefully provide a
tool where we could finally look for
these parts the problem of detection of
yes that was our Focus was how do you
how do you get around this this merging
problem so whether they're out there or
not uh we don't know we we're planning
to do a search for them but um it it
remains an open question and I think
just one of those fun astrophysics
Curiosities questions where the binary
players exist in the universe because
then you know you have binary Earth you
could have binary Neptune all sorts of
wild stuff that would you know flow to
the Sci-Fi imagination I wonder what the
physics on a binary Planet feels like it
might be trivial I have to think about
that I wonder if there's some
interesting Dynamics like if you're
multiple
or would gravity feel different on
different parts of the the surface of
the sphere when there's another large
sphere yeah I would think that the force
would be uh fairly similar because the
shape of the object would deform to a
flat Geo potential essentially a uniform
due potential but it would lead to a
distorted shape for the two objects I
think they've become ellipsoids facing
one another
um so it would be pretty wild when you
you know people like Flat Earth or
spherical Earth you fly from space and
you see a football shaped Earth yeah
it's your own Planet finally there's
proof and I wonder how difficult to be
to travel from one to the other
because you have to overcome the one
no it might be kind of easy
yeah I mean they're so close to each
other that helps and I think the most
critical Factor would be how massive is
the planet that's always I mean one of
the challenges with escaping plants
there was a fun paper when my colleagues
wrote that suggested that super Earth
planets may be inescapable if you're a
civilization that were born on a super
Earth the surface gravity is so high
that the chemical potential energy of
hydrogen or or methane whatever fuel
you're using simply is at odds with the
with the gravity of the planet itself
and so you would uh you know our current
Rockets I'm not sure with a fraction but
maybe like 90 of the rocket is fuel or
something by mass these things would
have to be
um like the size of the the Giza
Pyramids of fuel with just a tiny tip on
the top in order just to escape their
atmosphere and so it has been argued
that if you live on a super Earth
you may be you may be forced to live
there forever there may be no Escape
unless you invent a space elevator or
something but then how do you even build
the infrastructure and space to to do
something like that in the absence of a
successful rocket program
um and so the more and more we we look
at our Earth and think about the sorts
of problems we're facing
the more you see things about the Earth
which make it ideally suited in so many
regards it's almost spooky right that we
not only live on a planet which has the
right conditions for life for
intelligent life a sustained fossil fuel
industry just happens to be in the
ground we have plenty of fossil fuels
that to get our Industrial Revolution
going
um but also the chemical energy
contained within those fossil fuels and
hydrogen and other fuels is sufficient
that we have the ability to escape our
planetary atmosphere and planetary
gravity to have a space program and we
also happen to have a Celestial body
which is just within reach the moon
which doesn't also necessarily have to
be true were the moon not there what
effect would that have had on our
aspirations of a space program in the
1960s would there have ever been a space
race to Mars or to Venus it's a much
harder it's only for a human program
that seems almost impossible with 1960s
technology to imagine ever come to
fruition it's almost as if somebody
constructed a set of uh challenging
obstacles before us challenging problems
to solve they're challenging but they're
doable and there's a sequence of them
gravity is very difficult to overcome
but we have given the size of Earth it's
not so bad that we can still actually
construct propulsional systems that can
escape it yeah and the same with climate
change perhaps I mean climate change is
the next major problem facing That
civilization but we know it is
technically surmountable yeah you know
it's it's a it's it's it does seem
sometimes like there has been a series
of challenges laid out to progress us
towards a mature civilization that can
one day perhaps expand to the Stars I'm
a little more concerned about nuclear
weapons uh Ai and uh natural or
artificial pandemics but yes I mean
plenty plenty of plenty of fun
Milestones that we need to cross and we
can argue about the severity of each of
them but there is no doubt that we live
in a world that has serious change is
that are pushing our intellects now will
to the limit of
whether we're really ready to progress
to the next stage of our development